two well this may seem like deja vu
american airlines now the latest carrier
to cancel thousands of flights this just
over the last weekend we have problems
on the roads now problems in the air
again bianca holman live from mccarran
airport with the impact that folks may
be feeling here if you're headed out the
door bianca
hey good morning heather good morning
john a true nightmare being stranded in
the airport delayed flights your flight
not coming until two days later a matter
of fact we looked at the mccarran
website and as of right now there are
about seven departures that are canceled
so again if you're visiting or if you're
headed out
across the country definitely take a
look at your flight status if you are
traveling with american so there were
massive lines of hundreds trying to get
to customer service desk at airports
across the country from friday to sunday
american canceled more than one thousand
flights the company says it's due to
severe winds at its primary hub in
dallas fort worth texas and a shortage
of flight attendants
thousands of whom took leave during the
pandemic
now these are the same reasons that
southwest said they had their issues and
delays a few weeks ago some passengers
say their flight was canceled five
minutes prior before prior to boarding
repeated delays or only being able to
catch a flight two days later
so very very frustrating weekend for so
many passengers across the country so
again if you're flying with the mccarran
go ahead check your status before coming
to the airport again there are about
seven flights that are canceled this
morning departing from mccarran with
american airlines bianca holman live
local now